près d'un mètre 80 en 2016 le quartier
de Grousset à Rambouillet se retrouvait
sous les eaux un quartier à nouveau
touché en 2018 pour y pallier un bassin
de stockage des eaux va bientôt voir le
jour l'idée c'est de pouvoir absorber
les épisodes plus vieux majeurs c'est à
dire qu'en fait les masses d'eau qui
peut arriver maintenant on a vu de
manière très intense très localisée il
faut qu'on ait ce bassin il va pouvoir
faire tampon c'est-à-dire absorber le
temps de pouvoir faire en sorte que la
station qui est en aval traite
correctement la flux d'eau qui aurait
lieu d'un coup un chantier qui s'inscrit
dans le schéma directeur
d'assainissement réalisé à la fin de
l'année 2018 sur les communes de
Rambouillet Gazeran et vieille église et
une grosse attente pour les riverains ce
qu'on a vu là c'est quand même très
intéressant c'est rassurant aussi pour
nous pour notre avenir et puis
concernant aussi de refaire le parc
ensuite pour les enfants et tout voilà
il faut quelque chose de bien et que il
y en a pour tout le monde rassurer d'une
part mais curieuse quand même de voir
quel sera l'évolution
en particulier des nuisances et des
voilà des vibrations le bassin sera en
complément de celui de Gazeran grand de
7500 m3 le skatepark sera démonté avant
de retrouver sa place d'autres réunions
seront prévues tout au long des travaux
durée prévu du chantier un an pour un
coup de 9 millions d'euros